♪ ♪
>> Sean: LINDSEY GRAHAM IN
SOUTH CAROLINA TONIGHT CALLING
FOR HEARINGS ON COVERT QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING THE WUHAN VIROLOGY
LAB.
AS WE CONTINUE TO LEARN THE LAB
LEAK THEORY WAS IN FACT
PLAUSIBLE AND CREDIBLE ALL
ALONG.
WE ARE ALSO LEARNING 2020 REPORT
UTILIZED BY THE STATE DEPARTMENT
CONCLUDED THAT A LAB LEAK WAS
PLAUSIBLE, EVEN AS DR. DOOM AND
GLOOM, DR. FLIP-FLOP FAUCI
DOWNPLAYING AND DESPITE BEING
WARNED ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY IN
HIS PRIVATE EMAILS AND BREAKING
TONIGHT, GET THIS, A NEW STUDY
FROM THE CLEVELAND CLINIC IS
FINDING THAT UNVACCINATED PEOPLE
WHO HAD COVID HAVE ZERO
DIFFERENCE IN REINFECTION
COMPARED TO THOSE WHO HAD THE
VIRUS AND THEN ALSO TOOK THE
VACCINE.
TRANSLATION: WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING TONIGHT, IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE THERE IS A NEED TO
VACCINATE THOSE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
THE VIRUS.
IT LOOKS LIKE SENATOR RAND PAUL
WAS RIGHT AGAIN.
HERE TO REACT TO ALL OF THIS
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
LET'S FIRST START WITH THE
CLEVELAND CLINIC AND THIS NEW
KNOWLEDGE SAYING, AND BY THE
WAY, A LOT OF DOCTORS THAT I
HAVE BEEN INTERVIEWING ON MY
RADIO SHOW AND ELSEWHERE HAVE
BEEN SAYING THE SAME THING EVEN
IF THE ANTIBODIES GO DOWN THE
T-CELL IMMUNITY WHERE WHERE THE
BODY WOULD RECOGNIZE, IF, IN
FACT COVID WAS REINTRODUCED TO
YOUR BODY.
>> WELL IT MATTERS A LOT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
VACCINE SO INFECT PEOPLE WHO HAD
COVID-19 PREVIOUSLY DON'T NEED
THE VACCINE FREES UP A LOT OF
SHOTS FOR PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
SO SCIENCE MATTERS HERE BUT THE
BIG STORY, THIS IS THE RUSSIAN
DOSSIER ALL OVER AGAIN.
THIS STINKS TO HIGH HEAVEN, LAB
GATE, TRYING TO GATE, WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
REMEMBER WHEN DONALD TRUMP
SUGGESTED THIS CAME OUT OF CHINA
WITH A LAB LEAK?
REMEMBER THAT?
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THEY
STARTED THE CROWN OF VIRUSES,
AND WE ALL KNEW THAT THEY DID
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
>> WE ALL KNEW THAT AND THEY
HAVE FOR LEAKS OUT OF THE LABS
IN THE PAST.
BUT FEBRUARY 19, 2020, WHEN WE
HAD THE FIRST CASES IN JANUARY,
27 SCIENTISTS SIGNED A LETTER
THAT SAID "CONSPIRACY THEORIES
CREATE NOTHING BUT RUMORS AND
PREJUDICE THAT JEOPARDIZE OUR
GLOBAL COLLABORATION TO FIGHT
AGAINST THIS VIRUS."
IN OTHER WORDS, 27 SCIENTIST
SIGNED A POLITICAL DOCUMENT
SHAMING, TRUMP AND SHUTTING THEM
UP.
THE MEDIA OF TOOK IT AND RAN AND
IT CHANGE THE COURSE OF THE
ELECTION, WHY?
NUMBER ONE THE SCIENTISTS ARE
TIED TO THIS LAB.
THEY WERE COVERING THEIR ASS BUT
A POLITICAL DOCUMENT TO DESTROY
THAT IT CAME OUT OF A LAB.
WHY DOES THIS MATTER?
TRUMP WAS RIGHT ABOUT THE LAB
LEAK IT WOULD CHANGE THE IMAGE
REGARDING THE CORONAVIRUS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY IF IT CAME OUT
OF THE LAB IN CHINA, HE WAS
RIGHT IT WAS THE CHINA VIRUS.
IN THE 2020 ELECTION WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABOUT WHO CAN HOLD TRAIN
ACCOUNTABLE.
CHUMP POTOMAC TRUMP OR BIDEN AND
WHO WOULD YOU WANT CHINA TO TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
INFECTING THE WORLD?
>> Sean: IS THAT A RHETORICAL
QUESTION BECAUSE THE ANSWER IS
PRETTY OBVIOUS.
I THINK VLADIMIR PUTIN AND I
THINK PRESIDENT XI WOULD EAT
BIDEN'S LUNCH WHICH IS
FRIGHTENING FOR THE U.S. AND
FRANKLY EMBARRASSING.
HERE IS WHAT WE DO KNOW.
TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED CASE OF CORONA,
JANUARY 31ST, THE DAY THAT
DONALD TRUMP PUT THE TRAVEL BAN
CALLED HYSTERICAL, THAT SAME DAY
DR. FAUCI RECEIVED AN EMAIL
SAYING THAT IT LOOK LIKE THE
GENOME SEQUENCE SHOWED
MANIPULATION IN A LAB OF THE
VIRUS.
THAT IS TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
CASE IN THE U.S.
THEN WE SEE A SERIES OF EMAILS,
SEE, I WOULD CALL THEM CI CIA
TALKING ABOUT WHETHER THEY FIND
AT THIS WHETHER GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH WAS BEING DONE WITH
AMERICAN MONEY.
AN OUT RIGHT PANIC BY FAUCI.
BUT FAUCI WENT BEFORE CONGRESS
AND HE SAID THINGS THAT DIRECTLY
CONTRADICTED WHAT WE NOW KNOW
WAS IN HIS OWN EMAILS.
>> IT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THAT.
YOU KNOW, YOU DID A HELL OF A
JOB EXPLAINING THE RUSSIAN
DOSSIER TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND HOW THEY IGNORED EVERY
STOP SIGN.
THEY WANTED AN OUTCOME.
NOT ONLY DID FAUCI IGNORE THE
WARNINGS, ON FEBRUARY 19TH,
COUPLE OF WEEKS AFTER THE FIRST
CASE, 27 SCIENTISTS PRODUCED A
LETTER SHAMING THOSE WHO
SUGGESTED THE LAB LEAK THEORY.
CALLING THEM CONSPIRATORIAL.
A RIGHT WING NUT MARGINALIZING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND TOM COTTON
BECAUSE IF TRUMP WAS RIGHT IT
WOULD CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF THE
2020 ELECTION, I BELIEVE.
IF WE COULD HAVE PROVEN IT EARLY
ON IN 2020 THAT IT WAS A LAB
LEAK COMING FROM CHINA, NOT
OCCURRING NATURALLY COME WITH
THE PUBLIC WOULD WANT REVENGE
AGAINST CHINA.
WHO WOULD THEY TURN TO?
BIDEN OR TRUMP?
I THINK THIS LETTER BY THE
SCIENTIST WAS ORCHESTRATED BY
SOMEBODY TO SHOOT DOWN THE IDEA
OF A LAB LEAK BECAUSE THEY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR OWN ASS
BEING IN THIS LINK BECAUSE OF
CHINA AND A POLITICAL MOTIVATION
TO DESTROY TRUMP'S CREDIBILITY.
IF IT WERE KNOWN IN FEBRUARY
THAT TRUMP WAS RIGHT IN 2020
COME I THINK HE WOULD BE
PRESIDENT TODAY.
>> Sean: IF I DID SUCH A
GOOD JOB WITH THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION, CAN YOU PLEASE
EXPLAIN WHERE THIS GUY DURHAM
IS?
HAS THERE BEEN A DURUM SIGHTING
IN THE LAST YEAR?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE REPORT?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE WORK HE WAS
DOING, WHERE WERE THE REFERRALS
OF MICHAEL HOROWITZ
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT?
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, AND
WATCHING WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
WAY THE LIBERAL MEDIA MOB AND
DEMOCRATS ARE REACTING TO
JOE MANCHIN WHO ACTUALLY SEEMS
TO HAVE READ THE CONSTITUTION
AND UNDERSTANDS THAT NO VOTER
I.D., NO SIGNATURE VERIFICATION,
NO CHECKS AND BALANCES OR
INTEGRITY IN ELECTIONS IS A BAD
IDEA.
AND HE IS BEING CALLED
EVERYTHING FROM A RACIST ON
DOWN.
SAME WITH SENATOR CINEMA.
IN THE SAME WITH GETTING RID OF
THE LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER.
AS YOU LOOK AT JOE BIDEN'S
AGENDA, IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S RIGHT
OUT OF BOLSHEVIK BERNIE AMO READ
OUT OF THE RADICAL NEW DEAL
SOCIALIST GREEN SQUAD AND OUT OF
TOUCH WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HOW DOES THIS PLAY OUT AS WE HAD
TO 2022?
>> WELL COME I THINK IN 2022, IT
WILL BE A CHECK AND BALANCE
ELECTION.
WE WILL WIN THE HOUSE MOST
LIKELY TAKE BACK THE SENATE
BECAUSE THE AGENDA THEY ARE
PUSHING IS NOT THE AGENDA THEY
RAN ON.
THE JOE BIDEN THAT IS PRESIDENT
TODAY IS NOT THE JOE BIDEN THAT
RAN IN 2020.
MODERATE JOE IS DEAD AND GONE IN
THE SQUAD RUNS JOE BIDEN.
I THINK WE WIN BECAUSE THEY ARE
HIS OVERREACH.
BUT I HOPE YOU WILL STAY ON THIS
CHINA DEAL.
THE SCIENTIST WHO WROTE THIS
LETTER TO TAMP DOWN AND TO
UNDERCUT ANY IDEA THAT COULD
HAVE COME BY THIS LAB TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN BUTT AND IT CHANGE THE
COURSE OF THE ELECTION.
DON'T LET THIS GO, SEAN.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN IN
NORTH CAROLINA.
>> I THINK WHEN JOE BIDEN SAYS
WE NEED CONFIDENCE IN RESULTS
AND THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
MUST DO TO ENSURE INTEGRITY,
WHEN PROSECUTES THE CHASE
AGAINST JOE BIDEN AND RADICAL
SOCIALISM AND LAYS OUT THE
AMERICAN FIRST AGENDA TO MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AGENDA,
THOSE THREE THINGS, I THINK,
LEAD TO A REPUBLICAN WAVE
ELECTION IN THE NEXT TWO
ELECTIONS, AM I WRONG?
>> NO, YOU'RE DEAD RIGHT.
FREEDOM WINS OUT IF IT IS
PROSECUTED RIGHT.
THEY ARE DOING E